On Tuesday, two major car companies announced investments in ride-hailing apps,...
...signaling both a growing role for on-demand cars...
...and a new groundwork for app-enabled self-driving fleets.
While Toyota will be investing and partnering with Uber,...
...Volkswagen is putting 300 million dollars into Tel Aviv-based ride-sharing app called Gett.
In their statement, Toyota emphasized new leasing options specifically for Uber drivers,...
...but made it clear that there would be deeper collaboration going forward.
Emil Michael, Chief Business Officer of Uber, said in a statement,...
..."Toyota vehicles are among the most popular cars on the Uber platform worldwide..."
"... and we look forward to collaborating with Toyota in multiple ways going forward,..."
"...starting with the expansion of our vehicle financing efforts."